this may be like this is actually so
uh tyson has his uh podcast that he does
on the tyson ranch yeah
and he and he's getting real with this
dude and this dude's like no you don't
believe that
and tyson punks the [ __ ] out of him the
and the
the way the guy changes his tune made me
laugh so hard he's like
oh no you're right dog you're right dude
he threatens the [ __ ] at him watch this
hey listen um you look at a guy like me
at this stage of my life i'm doing good
got a couple of 100 million dollars
properties and stuff right
and i hate myself no i know you don't
look at your [ __ ] you look at you look
at your [ __ ] look at do you gonna tell
me how i feel about myself
the more real [ __ ] who are you to tell
me who are you periods no
this is
this is just some people have you don't
know what i've seen that's so true
though
ah yeah that's so true
i haven't walked in your shoes yeah i
would love to hear tyson go
but it is how i feel no i know that is
right you are right right
but then again i think i'm beautiful i'm
a bad [ __ ]
okay and when i think like that that is
my sin that's my shame
my guilt but i'm the baddest man on the
planet
right um i hate being who i am and i'm
nothing
being from brownsville i'm nothing so i
actually invaded i created this
i am my god okay yeah
yeah no doubt man i feel that yeah you
know you're great
is that great yeah you made me laugh so
hard by the way
that switch happened quick tyson was
like this is who i am and i was like no
he's out he's like who the [ __ ] are you
and he's like you're right
that would piss me off too like i'm with
tyson on this like he's getting real and
he's like yeah
he's like no you don't he's like dude
how the [ __ ] are you gonna tell me that
that's not the truth
is he still like
just pure scary is he
top five you're like that's still a
scary [ __ ]
you did but you know you don't want to
see him fight you're not even gonna
watch the fight
so you don't think you think you could
take tyson yes
100 sure 100 does he know jiu jitsu
does he know wrestling no yeah it's
gonna be a nightmare i'm not gonna stand
and bang with him yeah no no no no how
many of those punches you think he could
take
none yeah but i'm not gonna
he's not gonna have opportunity how does
that take him down like this how does
that work
is does he have he i'm sure he has a
puncher's chance on your way in
to land one punch right you should be
tough dude is that right
because you have to educate me please so
say you got a boxer who doesn't know
jiu jitsu at all but it's like the conor
mcgregor floyd mayweather fight right
so if if if it was a street fight
because floyd mayweather doesn't have
knockout
power so find me somebody who could
knock you out with one punch
i mean floyd can especially for the
common fan but but not with but connor
right so say tyson could knock you out
with one punch for sure
anybody but if a guy knows jiu jitsu
because you're standing up in front of
each other isn't there
even a second where you're standing up
in front of each other where he has a
chance to land a punch
you'd be tough especially someone who's
like experienced that tell me why
because you can close the gap so much
and control his hands and just trip him
down to the ground
and then you're gonna land in full mount
yeah i don't know like i don't know
enough so because you're gonna come in
just
fully and he's gonna throw one or two
sure but
you know you're going to block that i i
so if you were going to say somebody who
only knows jiu jitsu and
only boxer the jiu jitsu guy will beat
him 99
times out of 100 is that right bar fight
or in the ring 99 times out of 100.
unless he unless you like say he gets
lucky and that punch gets through
but if it's a guy who's covering up and
then trips him down right
[ __ ] even if you're starting say you're
even if you're starting at a distance
and you can back up a little bit none of
that matters
i don't separation i mean he might be
able to land an uppercut but if it's a
guy who knows
like at least some fundamentals and
distance control yeah and he throws that
punch and he just slips under and grabs
a hold of him you're [ __ ]
did you guys be a boxer 99 times out of
100. and does it matter if it's in
public or in a ring
does either place favor either one it
doesn't matter
i i man that's the scariest
like a line and a shark and then you're
you're putting that line in the water
mine's [ __ ] dude no shot no shot
unless that one lucky punch lands this
is the scene
on that because jiu jitsu guys can look
like ed o'neill
sure do you know what i mean like it
used to be if you went to a two
reference but sure
but but or kenny florian yes like you've
seen kenny
the only reason you're like oh that's a
dork oh [ __ ] that gap
ed o'neal somebody's grandpa dude and he
could beat the [ __ ] out of most average
people yes
isn't it like a purple boat i think he's
a black belt over
under horry and gracie that's pretty
impressive right
yeah i mean al bundy is 90 dude but you
know and he's moves like a tortoise but
i'm saying like the best example is like
kenny florian
or uh who's who's kenny floyd's boy
the the the jitsu wizard oh uh ryan hall
ryan hall
you've seen ryan hall bring up if you
saw him in a bar and he was trying to
steal
a girl like you would you'd you're
bigger than him you'd be like dude
i'm gonna twist your [ __ ] neck off
he'd be like oh really
and he's the best in the world in jiu
jitsu and this guy
yep that that guy
will twist your [ __ ] so not only will
he twist your face off but he's got the
same muscle tone as jared goff
yep and he will shatter your ankle into
70 000 places
you'll be doing rehab for the next three
years
that it that's bananas to me he beat the
show mike tyson
for real without a doubt beat the [ __ ]
out of them and is this all like when
you
and again help me jiu jitsu a little bit
is jiu jitsu
is that where you're using somebody
else's body weight against them
somewhat i mean the the original uh form
of jitsu was made for smaller guys beat
bigger guys but there's some of that to
it but also
he's just so technically sound like look
at him dude
i i don't like kenny on the left like
you get the [ __ ] out of my face
he's going to beat the brakes off you
how heavy is this dude
fights at 55. so he's probably walked
around
165 170 but just thin
and just a dork it's like this dude
looks like a long distance runner yep
do you know what i mean like if you were
like he's holding his boston marathon
trophy
like good for him yeah he looks great
monster i
those guys are out there yeah that's the
scary thing about bar fights now is that
over that's don't get no no no you know
i'm not no i'm not either i mean i might
wipe
dog [ __ ] on your window but i'm not sure
and run away
i'm not either i'm not getting in a
street fight no ryan hall's a nightmare
dude
when i get off stage at the lap factory
right away you go bro
i figured out what you look like i'm
like what this from a bunch of other
comics i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic song